más de 2,8 millones de personas han sido
afectadas por las inundaciones en
Nigeria la temporada de lluvia que
empezó en junio podría continuar varias
semanas y se espera que aumente la
necesidad de ayuda humanitaria
todas mis pertenencias estaban bajo el
agua simplemente corrimos y salimos por
la mañana pensé que mis hijos se habían
despertado antes que nosotros pero no
pude ver a nadie
según las Naciones Unidas más de 600
personas murieron y 1,3 millones fueron
desplazadas
llegó con su bebé de dos semanas al
campo de aguada
de vuelta vi que mi casa estaba inundada
no puedo quedarme en ningún sitio así
que me dirigí al campamento
Cuando llegamos allí no vivimos igual
que en casa
Las ovejas advirtieron de la
vulnerabilidad particular de los niños
las inundaciones multiplicaron los casos
de cólera en el país Nigeria está
afectada por una de las peores
temporadas de lluvias que haya conocido
en su historia 34 de sus 36 estados han
sido tocados por las lluvias que
destruyeron casas y carreteras pero
también infraestructuras y cultivos
este suceso es extremo no es nada que
Nigeria haya visto en mucho tiempo y es
el resultado del cambio climático pero
tampoco es el único factor también
podemos hacer algo al respecto para
reducir nuestra vulnerabilidad mejorando
nuestro sistema de protección
modernizando nuestras infraestructuras
de adaptación global de la universidad
estadounidense
nejeria se encuentra entre las 20
últimas naciones respecto a su capacidad
de adaptación al cambio climático